the five most amazing moves
of miquel tau one of my favorite ever
players probably my
favorite player of all time this guy
was an absolute genius crazy genius
but genius remember to like and
subscribe to this channel
and take your pick of what move
of his you like the best leave your
comments below
let's move straight into the action this
first example
was tau playing with the white pieces
against
hans zhou team hect and
hans now played b5 most
normal human beings which tao certainly
wasn't he was a blooming
genius would think oh my queen's attack
let's move the queen
but oh bloomingly no no no
here he played the amazing pawn
takes f6 the first queen sack of his
top five moves i've picked and after he
loses his queen that pawn
continues rampaging by taking on g7
tau was often about attacking keeping
his opponents king
stuck in the middle and here the black
king cannot
castle anywhere but he's a queen down so
what on earth was his idea
after rook to g8 and of course he saw
this move in advance
can you play in a similar brilliant
style to tau bishop to f5
oh just imagine sliding that bishop in
there
and the point now is this queen has
nowhere good to go
there's a rook coming to e1 in a lot of
positions if the queen
takes the bishop knight d6 check
wins material back with a fantastic pawn
on g7 which will win the game
and after bishop f5 what else can be
played well if queen takes c4
that king is now stuck with nowhere to
run
and we just play rook to e1
and the king is dead try as you like
you can try defending but it's not gonna
work i'll let you guys work that
out the game continued knight takes h4
but after bishop takes e6 bishop a6
knight d6 check tao managed
to keep his positional advantage because
if you look at black's pawns they look
horrendous
he's got his material back and he went
on to win typical tao
who needs a queen when you're a genius
let's move on to example number two
well this is a famous example of towels
against mizloth
tower with the white pieces tau
was incredibly strong at attacking you
could say
the strongest ever and smithloff at the
time was one of the best players if not
the best player
in the world and here comes along tau
playing in a very flamboyant manner
which
was just his style knight to f6
from smith's loft what did tao now play
can you see it
i'll give you a clue if you're not
struggling to find tao's move
just get your queen and try to give it
up you know this is it
have the queen mr smithloff queen
takes f7 and this combines
elements of trying to attack on the back
rank with
maybe even a little smothered mate if
you know that little trick
the point is this queen could not be
captured because now the back rank
is too weak and you could end up getting
in a beautiful checkmate like this with
the black pieces
so what else can black play the fret is
just queen takes rook
he tries queen to a1 at least now the
rook
is blocked and after a couple more moves
things clarify quite quickly and tau
through the use of this very clever
tactic has the extra exchange and he
goes on to convert this
in brilliant style remember just give up
your queens for the next example or am i
tricking you
this third example a little bit easier
just remember
try to get rid of that queen and also
have some points of trying to checkmate
your opponent's king that is after the
end of the game and the aim of the game
what is the move for white here remember
pause if you
need to knight takes d4
his opponent was unnamed here probably
from a simultaneous display but
you can see this kind of simple idea of
opening the rook towards f7 i know it's
easy but
hey ho come on just think about the
beginners out there we've got to give
them something to
you know have a little go at you know a
bit of broad diversity
and the point of course if black
captures the queen
rook takes f7 is checkmate that black
king
in a very amusing net with the rook and
knight
the game continued knight takes e5 and
how do we follow the tactic through
the knight is the only piece defending
checkmate so we try to divert that
knight away
with queen takes g4 at the same time
winning a piece
and if the knight takes it will be
checkmate tao has gained
a clearly winning position there mikhail
tao
playing white against boris gucco
who went on to become world blitz
champion and
extremely strong ground master in his
own right it's tower to play
his queen has been attacked are you
getting a kind of general theme here a
general trend
does he move the queen does he hell
rook takes g7
and this is a stunning idea you're just
trying to rip
the protection of the black king away
this bishop
such a strong piece we have another
white rook that can come into the attack
and after this stunning move black is
helpless
gucco tried taking the
queen on e5 there's nothing better there
if king takes rook we can
bring our rook in check and now the nice
simple move queen g3 and there's no
adequate way for black to stop
queen to g7 check
and what is tau's point after pawn takes
e5 well this is now a tactic called the
windmill maybe you're
used to the windmill technique rook to
f7
check and here
what if the king goes to g8 we can first
play
knight takes e7 so the bishop can't get
to g5 and then
rook to g1 leading to checkmate
so the king tried going to e8 but now
rook takes e7 and it's a double check
part of this windmill technique king to
f8
rook to f1 check king to g8 and now the
very
smooth and delicate finish you got it
now
rook on f2f7 with
knight to f6 coming rook to g7 coming
all the towels pieces
swarming the board in a very picturesque
way
a lovely lovely finish there from
the legend this last example is
quite a tough one you're probably
expecting a queen sacrifice aren't you
would i
would i do a queen another queen
sacrifice could i do five in a row
tau has the white pieces against johann
hotterson
of iceland a grand master very strong
player
and in this position he plays a move
which is simply
astonishing can you see it
rook to c5 you were expecting a queen
sack
i disappoint sometimes and the pointless
move this really bizarre move which i
think is hard to see because we're not
capturing anything
we're not really doing anything that is
visually like wow
but we are simply threatening to win a
pawn
trying to demolish this pawn structure
that black has in the center
by tempting the base of that to move
if charterson had now taken the rook we
see tao's idea he can
bust through knight takes e5
and now there's a deadly discovered
check
on the agenda this knight is threatening
to take or move to d7 for example bishop
takes c6 the knight goes to d7
check we win the queen next move a
better defense would be
something like knight to f6 trying to
block the queen
but after knight takes d7 the knight
wins some material
and attacks the queen the queen moves
and now simply
knight takes c5 these knights are
jigging
a very nice dance in the center of the
board
the artisan could have got the queens
off this didn't occur it was a variation
but now with white playing something
like knight d4 his
strong central pass pawns and the fact
that he's going to win another pawn
give him a winning position the game
ended after this
stunning rook c5 queen to a6
but now tau simply took on b5 picking up
a pawn
gaining a winning position and he
artisan had no
answer to this so a beautiful way
to finish tao's five most amazing moves
like i've mentioned before there's so
many
blooming good tower moves some stunning
examples there remember to like
and subscribe to this video i could have
done
50 tal brilliant moves so it's very hard
to just find
five but as you can see he had a real
talent for the attack and for being very
generous with his queen did you have a
favorite move i'd like
you to discuss below did you even see
that rook c5 move if you did
you're doing very very well thank you
for now
hopefully i'll be back again soon with
more magic